non capirò mai ragazzi perché quando
gioca sta roba mi riduco così ma
continuiamo che è meglio per quello il
mio pene a my own penn effettivamente no
no no no no no no no no no no chi è
bravo bravo amico mio bravo così ti
voglio cosi tu tu non avrai lo stesso
mio pene ma ma se il bravissimo bravo
così a schiaffi a schiaffi per ragazzi
io sono sono solo nudo sono nudo è bello
fantastico forse bello no ma nudo sicuro
voglio capire dove cazzo mi sono di
nuovo qua ragazzi uomo nudo con pennelli
fuori c'è anche che zoppica cerca cazzo
cazzo cazzo aiuto
[ __ ] capiti no no no no non dirmi
che non si apre però tesoro [ __ ]
[ __ ] e tua sorella
guarda dall'ora di vista al fermo però
perché no no no no nostri scatti non mi
piacciono si scateno mi piace porca
[ __ ] ragazzi agli 8 come donna uscita
sull'uscita di qua dove cazzola vede
l'uscita guarda se senti fa infatti sto
tizio piuttosto che cazzo non dovevo
faccia di qua no no mi hai rotto le
palle però a franco si sono un
pervertito lui non lo sapevo le ragazze
del niente niente ma ha preso non c'è
verso no io non so come fare costo di
sabbia the party che tanto sembra
frankenstein e grosso come una casa
via di qui via di qui per favore via di
curie dove dopo di qua quel caso c'è
quella stanza perché mi fai questo ma va
a sparkle ragazzi non so dove cazzo
andare da temi vi prego una mano vi
prego una [ __ ] mano di qua dicono
vista veloce però cazzo chiudi gioca sui
dove sto andando
no no no di qua di cori per questo sto
cazzo di quantico ragazzino su c'è
un'ansia che mi avete idea con ansia che
non avete una [ __ ] idea non è
possibile ma dove cazzo sta dando un
bello dove sta andando
non vedo dove sta andando merda guarda
scavalca ti prego sì sì sì veloce però
giu sullo me ne frega un cazzo ti butti
di testa anche
bravo così voi volete tutte lasciarmi da
di morire atrocemente così vuoi
lasciarmi bene vai tu arresto di quelle
[ __ ] ingrate ma [ __ ] cioè
quello non si butta mi sono buttato io
lui no piuttosto che a prendermelo h
pranzi mi sono buttato da una finestra è
stata è stata una cosa atroce io non ho
parole giuro che poi ancora hanno capito
dove sfonda uscita c'è scritto uscita da
tutte le future parti ma cazzo se ne
fosse una vera e non ne possiede la
chiave
cosa c'è scritto e ti se non a chiave
proprio la breve allora sei stronzo
forte pure a chiave ci vuole un nuovo
obiettivo trovare a chiave per accedere
alla la maschile ma non ci tengono
accedere alla maschile cazzo da quello
di prima non andava bene che ragazzi
come ha fatto c'è ma spiegatemi come
questi sono tutti quelli che ha
torturato
ma che cazzo no io non c'ho parola volte
non me le spiego certe cose ma non
importa
andiamo avanti cosa mi cucina sentire
non solo donna quindi non so preparare
un toast ci sono le chiavi qui ha
buttato anche la spazzatura però non è
che ci hai tu le chiavi zio
no no non mi sa che non cela le chiavi
affossi di qua ce lo posso prendere dica
io non vorrei non vorrei salve sentano
né ghiaccia delle chiavi l'inverno ed io
io io vorrei sapere come cazzo ci è
finito qui dentro
ma forse è meglio lasciar fermò va beh
ma ndo ventre qua dentro c'è ma con
tutti i posti che c'erano proprio qua
dentro cazzo che questa questa è una
palestra sempre più ordinata di quella
della mia scuola e per carità perché ho
trovato una nuova tattica per non fare
educazione fisica però quando era un
ragazzino mia mamma ancora no no no non
basta è rotto il cazzo però non posso
faccio come faccio trovare una chiave in
un posto che grosso prof
scusi scusi ritardo prof non volevo la
ritardata l'autobus e sono arrivate rita
la chiave prof
perché regala perché hai rotto il cazzo
però hai rotto i [ __ ]
sì sì sì sì sul suo passato più di per
l'amor di dio
no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no via prè ragazzi
no kat tom io sono io sono figlio non
sono vivo tu te ne vai a fan tutte ne
vai a [ __ ] paesino fai il giro che
poi i nascondigli fa il giro bravo un
piano o un [ __ ] piano forse forse può
funzionare
ok ok forse non mi vede forse non mi
vede forse non mi vede con l'amico l'ha
visto l'ha visto il campo dove la può
dove dov'è no no no no lei non mi
ricordo più
non mi ricordo più dove rapporto non mi
ricordo chi dove la porta regale aeree
di qua e qua e là di come non sia
ricordato era di qua non c'è lancia una
memoria di una capra ragazzi sì sì sì
che ogni quanto non ci può arrivare
perché non c'ho le chiavi lurido pezzo
di merda se era
ecco questa l'uscita si uscita c'è
scritto uscita no no no no no no no no
però no però è però hai rotto un po il
cazzo è molto leggermente il calcio però
un'altra volta prova e riprova e tutte
mi tradite devi morire
no non ditemi che non minori e sotto
casa e tu puoi prendere come il resto di
loro no
cazzo madonna nei passati d amico mio ma
che cazzo sei un playboy madonna vanta
semmai era più pesante di quanto service
e così alla luna di miele non voglio
immaginare al nostro anniversario
che bel culo ragazzi non riesca cazzo
belle tette però ma allora io io vorrei
anche un po staccarmi di prima sì sì sì
sì a falco è crollato il tetto lega è
crollato il tetto ma mi sta tirando di
nuovo su hai rotto i [ __ ] però stai
ferma dannazione devi toglierti ma devi
toglierti madonna o dio o impiccato lui
come ho fatto come cazzo affatto
spiegatemelo prima avremmo potuto essere
così belli ma va morì ammazzato testa di
merda che è bello ragazzi un finale a
lieto fine proprio nella milza mi
dispiace mi come la l'amore fa male
certi sensi io io sono sono caduto da
qualsiasi posto che dal tetto di una
palestra da un balcone
ormai sono fatto d'acciaio praticamente
perché non è possibile dalle altre otto
ragazzi sono ancora nudo ora che mi ci
fate pensare mail world alla maschile
perfetto fatto tutto sto casino per
arrivare nella la maschile cosa che non
vuole non volevo comunque fare una cosa
ma cos'è cos'è rega stando a fuoco tutto
saranno a fuoco erano ma questa non è la
partita 8 lasko andavo a fuoco la chiesa
credo e non vorrei sbagliare non è che
siamo già arrivati a quel punto in
autras cep interessa questa sarebbe una
storia parallela a quella che ho fatto
l'altra volta quindi credo di sì credo
poi magari mi sbaglio non lo so casa
quello per piegare c'è un tizio o vista
ci siano più tizi e la sua tre gare sono
qui sono qui cazzo e il dottore lega
ecco è quello di outlaws normale allora
lì sono per niente sono già passato di
qua nell'altro outlast praticamente ma
aprire cazzo sono pure
ma perché quali mi hanno sparato
nell'altra auto quindi non è che ci
starei tanto d'accordo però è meglio che
niente mio dio agenti a terra al piano
interrato ragazzi necessitiamo di
vocazione dei paramedici che cazzo
dicono no vabbè ma non è possibile c io
non so io non c'è parola regala non so
veramente parole siamo arrivati in un
punto in cui c'è la slot e questo non la
caga di striscio arriviamo resistete
io devo essere salvato e cazzo non loro
era cosa noi siamo c'è un posto fi
decente nella trachea c'è gente a terra
tata mio dio macchia schifo ragazzi mi
spiegate dove sto dove sto andando di
preciso che non lo so che questi sono i
poster esplodono il primo outlast
praticamente solo che non ho capito dove
sto andando perché l'uscita era
dall'altra parte c'era la slot c'era la
[ __ ] swat
ok siamo alle questa è l'entrata sì sì
sì sì io falchi come cazzo fa essere
ancora vivo io sono ancora vivo
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no di mirino dimmi che non è con dimmi
che non l'hai fatto
nessuno deve sapere nessuno no no si
ammazza ammazza lo ammazzo libro otto
muore muore stronzo ragazzi come quello
sotto il pezzo di merda mia mi ha rotto
i [ __ ] dall'inizio alla fine non è
possibile adesso ci sono adesso ci si ma
mia mi hanno accoltellato però dovrei
essere vivo si trascina ti prego jean
jacques e prima volta definito di merda
almeno questo almeno questo due passi ti
prego 22 passi bravo bravo così brava
bello lo zio bravo bravo sì sì sì se
cazzo
ce l'abbiamo fatta dio mio ce l'abbiamo
fatta non ci posso credere non si voglio
che l'amica mi vien da piangere mi vien
da piano uscito sono uscito non è
possibile
a parte che sono sono nudo mi hanno
accoltellato cosa a caso
intanto questa è la macchina con cui
sono arrivato nell'altro outlast posso
prenderla ma qualcosa mi porto la
macchina del no no no no no
no no no no no no la radio la metti dopo
perché dobbiamo dobbiamo scappare
abbastanza velocemente
chi è quel tizio regala chi cazzo alcol
tizio chi cazzo è quel tizio io non me
ne frega un ca via via via
no non ho mica se no no no no ragazzi
indietro i veloci veloci veloci
no no non è possibile
veloce si si sfonda sì sì credo di
avercela fatta
spero già fatta questa dal signor parks
premere il tasto non potrà tornare
indietro finale ci sono abbastanza prove
in quel video per ricoprire di merd ai
nostri amici alla morte è uscito vivo da
molti mesi le abbiamo fatto di tutto per
coprire le sue tracce ai nostri amici
sono malvagi paranoici aziendali con
risorse che lei è troppo ingenuo per
immaginare non sarebbe l'unico obiettivo
tutti quelli a cui tiene sua moglie i
suoi figli con una volta che avrà
ricordo che il tasso la sulla vita della
sua vita sarà finita tutte le persone a
cui tiene saranno fottute ma è la cosa
giusta da fare
vale così tanto parla distruggere la
musica è un cast e facebook c'è anche il
tasto accedi praticamente ha filmato
tutto quello che io ho registrato fino
ad ora e lo sto per caricare su facebook
mi bannano dopo due secondi
allora ragazzi che faccio condivido ma
[ __ ] sa bene che o 6 ragazzi è un
documento ricevuto questo blauer ragazzi
abbiamo finito altra suisse the flowers
già la prima inter ragazzi è finito che
io io sono riuscito a scappare cosa
impossibile non avrei mai non ci avrei
mai sperato da un ok perché parole ho
registrato tutto quello che è successo
dall'inizio alla fine e ho mandato
questo questo video su facebook cosa
bellissima così in teoria poi tutti
quanti quelli della dell'agenzia sono
andati tutti a [ __ ]
solo che sono finita buttare anch'io
perché poi probabilmente mi ammazzeranno
perché sono tutti stronzi
io ragazzi non so che dire mi è piaciuto
tantissimo sto dlc perché dovrebbero
essere tutti così vlc cazzo sembrano era
un'altra storia completamente la
bellissima ragazzi dire che possono
includere qui come al solito se il video
è piaciuto da sotto commento mi piace
anche al cortina di facebook e come non
i video trovata nella descrizione se non
se ne vorresti di scrivere io ci
rivediamo il prossimo video bene ragazzi